okay let me go to our caller from the
585 who's calling today from 585 hi
David this is Kyle from Rochester in New
York hey Kyle what's going on beautiful
pristine connection by the way there's a
question about us the coronavirus sure
oh I'm in New York in New York we're
supposed to be in our peak really like
right about now yeah and it's supposed
to last for the week so according to its
projections we're not supposed to have
any more than 10 deaths a day after
April 30th so this will with this will
our state be able to reopen up or since
most states didn't implement any like
stay at home features we'll have to wait
longer my guess is that Andrew Cuomo
will probably start hello hello did you
hear me yeah there was just it's an ear
cut about a voice in the background
there that was weird
most likely New York is going to have to
start implementing some opening up so
it'll be like older folks should
probably still stay home medium to older
folks should stay home if they have any
kind of comorbidities younger people
people who have already recovered are
going to be able to start getting a lot
of elements of the economy going I think
that the responsible way would be to do
it slowly to see and try to avoid a very
quick second wave which likely is coming
in the fall anyway yeah so would you you
probably wouldn't see schools opening up
anytime soon exactly for the year I you
know I would be surprised if any schools
that have canceled so far go back
because many of them are would only be
going back for a few weeks or a month at
the most so I'm seeing more and more
places today schools done for now we're
gonna pick it back up in the fall okay
and then I have one more question if you
have time sir okay so with Bernie
dropping out today how can we convince
red rose Twitter to vote for Biden what
is red rose Twitter I don't even know
what that means
so it's a bunch of like people when you
see like the red roses and they owe it
they're the one oh boy
all right your connections imploding
some will go I'll try to figure out what
Red Rose Twitter is but continued up
connection issues today